[Musica]
lui non ha bisogno di presentazioni è un
protagonista di natura possiamo dirlo ma
oggi vogliamo fargli fare la parte di
una comparsa perché se ci fosse soltanto
lui
la terra probabilmente sarebbe più o
meno così come la luna con la
temperatura media che capite non
consentirebbe la vita
se invece la terra è meraviglioso
pianeta che vediamo bene
ciò è dovuto anche all'atmosfera e
all'effetto serra naturale
cosa vuol dire vuol dire sono delle
molecole che vediamo cure naturali queen
e artificiale in questa animazione che
sono trasparenti alla radiazione solare
ma sono invece parzialmente trasparenti
alla radiazione infrarossa che viene
emanata dalla terra questo vuol dire che
alcune vanno nello spazio alcune
rimangono a fare una specie di coperta
che mantiene la temperatura più costante
nel nostro pianeta
questa quantità di molecole di co2
principalmente che il cast principale si
misurano in parti per milione come
concentrazione e sarà una variabilità
naturale molto interessante come vedete
vedete qui vanno da 180 280 parti per
milione più o meno negli ultimi 800 mila
anni concentrazione che ricavato dalle
bollicine di gas delle carote di
ghiaccio dell'antartico bene da 180 a
280 parti per milione hanno portano alla
variazione alla variabilità tra ere
glaciali interglaciali capite che grande
variabilità che c'è tutto questo poi
arriviamo noi scopriamo il carbone il
petrolio lo tiriamo fuori da sotto terra
e che succede è che questa
concentrazione passa da 280 crea valore
massimo a 415 parti per milione quale
l'implicazione di tutto questo lo
vediamo da una bellissima animazione
della nasa partiamo dal 1880 vedevo come
varia la temperatura nel pianeta e
vedremo che dal 1950 in poi ma
soprattutto dal 1970 in poi la
colorazione siamo al 50 adesso inizia a
variare in modo significativo in un modo
che non lascia più dubbio a quello che
sta succedendo in questo momento vedete
siamo il 2005 2012 e questo è molto
chiaro
osservate quella mattutina azzurra sotto
la groenlandia e un po più freddo li
dobbiamo stare tranquilli
no è un altro motivo di preoccupazione e
freddo perché c'è la fusione dei ghiacci
della groenlandia questo vedete la
variazione della massa dei ghiacci della
groenlandia come è cambiata negli ultimi
dieci anni sono ricordo male bene
guardate la zona periferica come sta
aumentando di temperatura si sta
fondendo il ghiaccio ghiaccio che
finisce in acqua raffredda l'acqua e poi
contribuisce anche l'innalzamento
livello degli oceani
ma non è solo la zona periferica anche
al centro c'è un problema importante
perché se il ghiaccio si fonde al centro
creando delle specie di laghetti questi
laghetti e una temperatura ovviamente
maggiore dell'acqua e questa piano piano
fa sì che l'acqua si infiltri lentamente
e vada a finire nella zona come dire di
confine tra il ghiaccio e la roccia e
che succede
scelta che lubrifica questa zona e se
lubrifica questa zona grande massa di
ghiaccio finiscono in acqua aumentando
ulteriormente quindi il contributo di
acqua negli oceani
bene allora chiediamo gli scienziati che
il futuro dovremmo aspettarci cosa ci
riserverà il futuro
e loro rispondono dipende dipende da
cosa dipende da quello che faremo noi
domani mattina oggi tra due giorni
allora identificano due scenari lo
scenario business as usual
chiamiamolo baù che vuol dire state
tranquilli non c'è niente da fare non
preoccupatevi e domani mattina ha
continuato a vivere come vivevate oggi e
ieri
oppure lo scenario azzurro
rimbocchiamoci le maniche
iniziamo a fare quello che è possibile
che la tecnologia già oggi ci dice che è
possibile
cosa cambia tra lo scenario bau
rimbocchiamoci le maniche che il bau a
fine secolo ci dà una prospettiva di 4
gradi l'aumento della temperatura
oggi siamo in grado lo scenario azzurro
un grado e mezzo però molti ci dicono
attenzione questo vuol dire uno
stravolgimento della vita come
conosciamo oggi dovremmo tornare nelle
caverne perdiamo lo stile di vita che
abbiamo oggi lo stile di vita bau appena
lo guardiamo quelle fantastico stile di
vita che abbiamo fino a questo momento
un uso delle fossili importante che ha
delle conseguenze altrettanto importanti
molte volte non con degli incidenti
oppure una mobilità assurda vediamo la
pubblicità delle macchine che ci fa
vedere le macchine e semplicità vuote e
mezzo alle campagne bellissime ma questa
è la realtà che noi viviamo tutti i
giorni oppure un allevamento degli
animali un cibo che viene fatto in modo
intensivo con tutte le criticità che
sono ad esse collegate oppure è un altro
scenario bellissimo dello scenario bau è
il fatto che la pianura padana ogni anno
puntualmente l'autunno diventa la zona
più inquinata d'europa e noi non
riusciamo a respirare un'aria sana ma
anche fantastico lo scenario bau perché
ci dà una uno stile di vita e
un'alimentazione molto sana come vediamo
in questa immagine oppure dei magnifici
scenari bellissimi questi paesaggi no di
rifiuti che sono il risultato del nostro
stile di vita
questo è il bau cui dovremmo rinunciare
e quindi hanno dimenticava un'altra cosa
importante
un grande equilibrio con la natura che
abbiamo in questo momento
bene quindi devo vedere invece come sarà
lo scenario cupo e potrebbe essere lo
scenario spinto di riduzione il tornare
nelle caverne come ci raccontano tornare
l le caverne vuol dire una mobilità
diversa una mobilità sostenibile molto
più leggera e pensata al trasporto delle
persone al servizio no alla macchina
oppure la produzione di energia da fonti
rinnovabili
ormai sono molto più competitive solo
competitive rispetto a quelle fossili
l'efficienza energetica usare meglio
l'energia che consumiamo e
l'elettrificazione quanti bici
elettriche vediamo ormai nelle città le
macchine elettriche stanno avvicinando
anche loro facendoci capire che si può
cambiare anche in questo tema
un'alimentazione più sana perché vuol
dire alimentazione più sana corpi più
sani e poi l'isolamento delle case
bisogna staccare solo dei lineamenti di
cartone che fanno passare l'energia
perdere energia moltissimo bene quindi
questo un altro evento molto importante
su cui dovremo lavorare e poi vivere
appunto in maggiore sintonia con la
natura
bene quindi non è poi così brutto questo
scenario dalle caverne no cosa dobbiamo
fare quindi per il cambiamento
beh innanzitutto cambiare i nostri
comportamenti
personali e questo è un po la sintesi
quello che ho visto fino a questo
momento
in seconda battuta dobbiamo cambiare i
nostri politici ma noi essere cambiarli
influenzare la politica facendo
pressione riders for fisher è un esempio
greta la conoscete tutti felici
finkbeiner altro ragazzo fantastico di
qualche anno fa altrettanto bravo quindi
cambiamo la politica interveniamo su
questo e poi dovremo aiutare a cambiare
la consapevolezza non possiamo dare
invece che tra noi e il nostro vicino va
col suv con motore acceso e l'aria
condizionata e tristi fra passato dovevo
cambiare la consapevolezza e noi questo
abbiamo introdotto un progetto ride with
us pedala con noi
lanciato nel 2014 guardate proprio
casualmente bevendo una tazzina di caffè
devo andare a copenhagen nello
giornalista seguirà la presentazione di
un rapporto sul clima appunto copenhague
andare in aereo fare gli urla conferenza
stampa a tornare a fare l'articolo 8 mi
sembra assurdo il mio amico ciclista ha
detto nemici in bicicletta ha detto ok
partiamo prendiamo da venezia in piena
autonomia con le nostre borse in seguito
e pensiamo non pedaliamo solo noi
invitiamo le persone parlare con noi qui
a roma monaco
un gruppo di attivisti che ci
accompagnato per molti chilometri e non
solo l'essere affacciamo dei convegni
dove dobbiamo riuscire a far parlare
della scienza questo filippo george
premio nobel con le pinces per la pace e
poi parla relativisti piramo innsbruck
con i giovani che fanno attivismo lei
arriviamo finalmente copenaghen ma 2015
siamo ripartiamo più gente ancora più
entusiasmo di parigi della conferenza
per il sì sul clima a torino per
sottolineare il legame trattamento
climatico e salute poi andiamo a bonn
nel 217 l'anno scorso a katowice e
gruppo sempre più grande e quest'anno
questa è la demo bruxelles abbiamo
presenta se partiamo il 27 ottobre da
venezia venezia bassano e faremo tappa
qui in piazza giorgione vicino al borsa
alle tre del pomeriggio io vi invito
tutti a venire con noi in bicicletta da
castelfranco fino a bassano dove ci sarà
una conferenza su vaglia la tempesta che
ha colpito le alpi del veneto raccontata
da chi ha gestito questo dal centro
meteo di teolo
adesso però volevo chiudere con voi in
un modo allegro perché non vorrei
chiusissimo dei quattri sti davanti alla
grande sfida che abbiamo
vorrei che avessimo l'energia di essere
un gruppo che assieme vuole muoversi per
il cambiamento e quindi vi chiedo un
piccolo sforzo ma lo chiedo tutti quanti
voi di cantare insieme un pezzo di una
canzone che secondo me è molto
importante tutti
il templare
[Musica]
va bene
chissà
[Musica]
[Applauso]